and I'm gonna talk to you about pressure
resistance and flow so we're gonna try
to make sure you feel real comfortable
with all three of these things by the
time we're done so we start with the
heart and off of the heart is the aorta
this is the largest artery in the body
and this is one branch of the aorta I
didn't draw a lot of the other ones this
is the brachial artery and the blood is
flowing from the aorta into the brachial
artery and let's say that the blood is
trying to make its way out to a
fingertip for example so on its way out
there it makes its way to an arterial
and the blood continues flowing and it
goes into a capillary bed and vessels
are too small to draw so I just kind of
do that thing and it then goes into the
other half of the capillary bed where
now the blood is deoxygenated so I'm
going to draw that as blue that's the
part where now the blood is without
oxygen and then it continues to go and
get collected into a venule which sounds
a little bit like the arterial on the
other side right we've got a vein over
here and then finally the blood gets
collected in a large vein called the
vena cava and they're actually two vena
cavas so this will be the superior vena
cava there's also an inferior vena cava
and the blood flow through this half is
as you would guess kind of continues to
go around and if I was to try to figure
out the pressures the blood pressures at
different points along this system I'm
gonna choose some points that I think
would be interesting ones to check so it
would be good probably to check what the
pressure is right at the beginning and
then maybe at all the branch points so
what the pressure is
as the blood goes from the aorta to the
brachial artery maybe as it ends the
brachial artery and enters the arteriole
maybe the beginning and the end of the
capillaries also from the venule to a
vein
and also wrapping it up what the
pressure is at the end now these numbers
or these pressures can be represented as
numbers right like what is the
millimeters of mercury that the blood is
exerting on the wall at that particular
point in the system and earlier we
talked about systolic versus diastolic
pressure and there we wanted to use two
numbers because that's kind of the range
the upper and the lower range of a
pressure but now I'm going to do it with
one number and the reason I'm using one
number instead of two is that this is
the average pressure over time
so the average pressure over time for me
you know keep in mind my blood pressure
is pretty normal it's somewhere around
120 over 80 in my arm so the average
pressure in the aorta kind of coming out
would be somewhere around 95 and in the
artery in the arm probably somewhere
around 90 again that's what you would
expect somewhere between 80 and 120 so
90 is the average because it's gonna be
not exactly a hundred because remember
it's spending more time in diastole and
relaxation than in systole so it's gonna
be closer to 80 for that reason and then
if you check the pressure over here by
this X probably something like let's say
80 and then as you cross the arterial
the pressure Falls dramatically so it's
somewhere closer to 30 and then here is
about 20 here's about 15 let's say 10
over here and then at the very end it's
gonna be close to a 5 or so so here let
me just write that again 10 and 5 and
the unit's here are millimeters of
mercury so I should just write that
pressure in millimeters of mercury
that's the unit's that we're talking
about so the pressure Falls dramatically
right so from 95 all the way to 5 and
the heart is a pump so it's gonna
instill a lot of pressure in that blood
again and pump it around and around and
that's what keeps the blood flowing in
one direction so now let me ask you a
question let's see if we can figure this
out let's see if we can figure out what
the resistance is in all of the vessels
in our body combined
so we talked about resistance before but
now I want to pose this question see if
we can figure it out so what is total
body resistance and that's really the
the key question I want to try to figure
out with you we know that there is some
relationship between radius and
resistance and we talked about vessels
and tubes and things like that but let's
really figure this out and make this a
little bit more intuitive for us so to
do that let's start with an equation and
this equation is really gonna walk us
through this this puzzle so we've got
pressure P equals Q times R really easy
to remember because the letters follow
each other in the alphabet and here
actually instead of peeling put Delta P
which is really change in pressure so
this is change in pressure and a little
doodle that I that I always keep in my
mind to remember what the heck that
means is if you have a little tube the
pressure at the beginning let me say
start PS is for start and the pressure
at the end can be subtracted from one
another and that gives you PS minus PE
equals Delta P so the change in pressure
is really the change from one part of
the tube to the end of the tube and
that's the first part of the equation so
next we've got Q so what is Q this is
flow and more specifically it's blood
flow and this can be thought of in terms
of a volume of blood over time so let's
say minutes so how much volume how many
liters of blood are flowing in a minute
or two minutes or whatever number of
minutes you decide and that's kind of a
hard thing to figure out actually but
what we can figure out well we can
figure out is that Q the flow will equal
the stroke volume and I'll tell you what
this is just after I write it the stroke
volume times the heart rate so what that
means is that basically
if you have if you can if you can know
how much blood is in each heartbeat so
if you know the volume per heartbeat and
if you know how many beats there are per
minute then you can actually figure out
the volume per minute right because the
beats would just cancel each other out
and it just turns out it happens to be
that I'm about 70 kilos that's me I'm 70
kilos and for a 70 kilogram person the
stroke volume is about 70 milliliters so
for a 70 kilo person you can expect
about 70 milliliters per beat and as I
write this let's say my heart rate is
about 70 beats per minute I feel pretty
calm and so it's not too fast
so the beats cancel as we said and I'm
left with 70 milliliters times 70 per
minute so that's about 4,900
milliliters per minute or if I simplify
that's a five about so the flow is about
five liters per minute okay so I figured
out the blood flow and that was simply
because I happen to know my weight and
my weight tells me the stroke volume and
I know that there's a change in pressure
and we got to figure that out soon and
lastly this last thing over here is
resistance and I'm just gonna I know
I've said it before I just want to point
out to you again the resistance is going
to be proportional to one over R to the
fourth and so just remember that this is
an important issue R is radius and
that's the radius of the vessel so let's
figure out this equation and how let's
figure out the the variables in this
equation and how it's gonna help us
solve the question I asked you know what
is the total body resistance okay so if
I have to figure out total body
resistance let me clear out the board
I've got let's say the hearts yeah I'd
like to do the heart in red and it's
pumping blood out my aorta
alright so blood is going out out of a
order and then it's going a branching
branching here branching here let's say
and then it's gonna branch some more and
it's gonna bring some more and you can
see where this is going
it's gonna keep branching and eventually
every branch kind of collects on the
venous side all the blood is kind of
kind of filtering back in slowly into
venules and veins and finally into a
vena cava and I should really draw this
going like that the blood is going to go
back into the vena cava so that's my
system and I got to figure out what the
total body resistance is here so if I
have a system drawn out for myself and I
happen to know that here I said 95 and
here I said the pressure was 5 then
Delta P equals 95 minus 5 which is 90
and I know that there are 5 liters of
blood flowing through per minute and
that was my cue so I could say 90 equals
5 liters per minutes actually let me
take a step back from that instead of 90
let me write the unit's 90 millimeters
of mercury equals 5 liters per minute
that was my flow that's my cue and I've
got Delta P here
and my resistance is the unknown so I'll
just leave that as R so let's just solve
for R so I'll move my flow to the other
side so R equals 90 divided by 5 which
is 18 and the units are a little funky
but I'll just write them out anyway
millimeters of mercury
time's minutes / meters so this is the
answer to my question what is the total
body resistance well we know what the
pressures are at the beginning and end
of our system and we know that the flow
has to be around five liters per minute
because that's based on my weight and my
heart rate therefore the resistance must
be 18 millimeters of mercury times
minutes over liters whatever that set of
Units means to you it's kind of an
abstract thing but but basically I want
to demonstrate to you that this powerful
equation helps us solve for what would
otherwise become a tricky problem to
figure out